[Music]
peace be with you welcome to the dean
show my next guest going to be talking
about isis
and he's going to be talking about these
armed individuals
one in particular who is stalking and
terrorizing
innocent muslim women in front of hamas
that he goes to
to worship god alone that's it and
we're going to be talking about a
terrorist attack many of them that are
just going under the radar
they're not even really being even
reported as much as
isis is and how the mainstream media is
actually recruiting for isis all this
and more
here on the d show of my next guest
don't go anywhere we'll be right back
[Music]
this is the dean show
how are you alhamdulillah thank god good
good good how long has it been since
well we've seen each other here and
there but when we had that uh program
at the earth said yeah was the last time
you were in dallas a couple years ago
probably
now you go there to worship like
people you know they go to a house of
worship to worship but so many people
they don't uh
come there to find a surprise at their
churches synagogues with people ak-47s i
mean is that where you're finding now
when you go to the irvine mosque
well irvine was uh
protested by some uh anti-muslim
uh i don't know extremists like
i would say that decided they'd have an
armed protest outside of the irving
masjid but nothing happened and the
police were there so it was pretty
uh much a non-event even though that
people had to think about it and prepare
for it
there's a picture right now people are
seeing that went viral you got the guy
who's uh holding was that m16
and he's right he's like he's stalking
this uh
muslim woman who's actually representing
the mother of
jesus mary wearing the hijab have you
seen this picture
no i haven't yeah so people are seeing
it right now he's like actually right
behind her
and he's got a mask on with the m16
that's really scary man
no people are all worked up there's a
lot of fear there's a lot of ignorance
there's a lot of anxiety
and it's directed at the muslim
community so
this is something that we have to be
aware of and try to
work through paris attacks yeah i mean i
think
uh the people who at the end
suffer the most i mean when we hear this
i mean
we pray that it's not a muslim you know
it's it's sad
well thank god it wasn't a muslim who
did the paris attacks it was isis
and isis is as un-islamic as
i mean they're they're hostile to islam
everything about them is unislamic
there is not one thing that i've heard
or seen or read
or understood about this organization
that has an ounce of islam in it
so alhamdulillah was not a muslim who
did anything in paris
but my heart goes out to those who are
the victims
of this injustice and of this atrocity
and for
anyone who suffers at the hands of
either ignorant people or zealot people
or whoever's
acting putting a label on something
and pretending to do something in the
name of something that they have nothing
to do with
i usually make this example you know
when i talk to our brothers in humanity
and it's it's sad that most people they
they end up believing everything that
they're fed from
the mainstream media but it would be as
though like kkk
uh was shown to him all day and night
and as if that represents smart enough
to know that that doesn't represent
christianity
and same is french the same thing as if
hitler said i'm a christian and you know
he invited you over for a bake sale you
know i mean
this is absurdity and i know that it's
confusing because
people only know what they hear or only
what they see and
you have an organization that is making
a lot of claims in the name of religion
and doing
atrocious acts of beheading and violence
and
just absurd uh hostile
[Music]
events and and and just and
and pretending to be in the name of
islam but i can assure you there's not
one muslim that i'm aware of and
my entire life is spent in the mosque
traveling the u.s every single day
visiting another community
and all i've seen is two thousand mosque
condemned the organization
two thousand imams say they have nothing
to do with the religion of islam
every major organization every out of
seven eight million muslims in america i
haven't heard one person support
anything about isis so this phenomenon
that we're all
up in arms about and that is a real
tragedy
i can't explain it but it has nothing to
do with my religion not
my name is this happening not in your
name is this happening not in
any muslims name that i know of in this
country is this happening
so but the people that don't know the
faith are not exposed to their
muslim neighbors people that aren't
frequent in a mosque or they don't know
what's happening in the muslim community
we have no idea
so they would have to judge by what they
see and if what they're seeing
is someone or some organization making
all these
[Music]
heinous claims and
and acts it just
it's beyond apologetics it's it's as
simple as
there there is nothing that this
organization has to do with the religion
other than claiming they're doing it
in the name of islam i i've also
it's a fact that they're actually
killing more muslims there
everywhere you go isis is killing
more muslims than anybody
even the the um
well that's a we'll just leave it that
way that this organization
is hostile to islam and every aspect of
the muslim community
and to our faith and to our our
teachings and to our representation
there is nothing in this religion that
would
ever encourage beheadings or suicides or
mass destruction of of people or
buildings or
populations or innocents nothing to do
with my religion
nothing uh so you have all the
mainstream
stream organizations have condemned this
uh you have muslims worldwide
who have condemned this uh why do you
think the media just
continues to give them the voice and the
platform and
kind of makes it like they represent i
don't know but to me it seems like the
media is recruiting for isis and i turn
on the tv and as much as i hate isis
all i hear is how effective and how
smart and how big and how strong
and how powerful this organization is
and we need to be afraid and we need to
be afraid
and i'm thinking of what i mean you've
got
uh eight billion muslims or one i don't
know how many muslims in the world today
but
uh one and a half two billion muslims uh
in the world today
who other than the the few that call
themselves this organization
are condemning writing left telling them
it has nothing to do with my faith
it doesn't have anything to do with the
history of islam so we're
we're at our wits end as to how to
move forward yet in my opinion the media
either through ignorance or through
sensationalism or for whatever
motivation they have
have actually you know hyped it to a
point where
it's beyond relevant it is
absolutely consuming the
the thoughts and the hearts and minds of
of
people all over the world and i'm not
here to
ever um condone
what isis is doing but the media is
making it worse
by giving them a platform a stage
a presence credibility in every way
by telling us to be afraid telling us
that it could happen to anybody and all
muslims are suspect and every mosque is
a threat
and every human you know everybody that
professes to be
a muslim is a potential threat because
of their belief
is just inciting people
to act upon the fear
without justification we're going to go
ahead and take a break and we'll be
right back with
more we want to talk about kind of the
double standard because we had some
uh many recent domestic terrorist
attacks that have happened we'll talk
about those and
registering muslims donald trump's whole
new you know agenda
all that and more here on the dean's
show don't go anywhere we'll be right
back
has nothing to do with my prophet
please just stop it it doesn't make any
sense that's not the message he sent
that's
not what he meant that's not why he came
so you can claim as much as you want to
but i assure you the
man i follow was not the same
see i know a man who forbade the cutting
down of a plan
who even spoke against those who had
birth and ant
so why is it that i simply can't
understand how we
claim to follow the same man
i mean i know a man who forbade us from
harming the innocent
saying he who does so would not only be
prohibited from paradise but he would
not even smell its scent so please tell
me how what you're doing has
anything to do with the message that he
sent
this is the man who forbade us from even
scaring cattle with a knife
saying you have no right to let the
animal die twice
and when he was asked for advice he'd
reply
don't get angry don't get angry don't
get angry
repeating it thrice please subscribe to
the d show follow us on our official
facebook and twitter pages in the links
below
please also help support the d show by
making a donation in the link below
back here on the dean show
so where we left out we're talking about
isis isis isis
is just um daesh that's their new this
is actually the proper name have you
heard this
yeah i mean the proper name is satanic
satanic demonic satanic
and prophet muhammad peace be upon off
and tell people he actually prophesies
of this kind of group like this actually
coming
uh you know about this this yeah he said
there would be people that come you know
every religion has talked about wolves
and sheep's clothing yeah this is
our wolf in sheep's clothing or without
the sheep's clothing
yeah so it's just pretty blatant what it
is
but someone says look look but they're
screaming uh allahu akbar
you know before they kill people um you
know this is islam
what do you say you know because they're
screaming this
this uh yeah yeah they can pretend
all they want that they can say arabic
words they can say
arabic phrases they can say muslim
words and even quote parts of the quran
but
nothing that this organization has done
has said or i'm aware of has anything to
do with my religion
and i consider myself a fundamentalist
muslim in every sense of the word and i
would never hurt another human being
for any reason for any unjust cause i
wouldn't ever
do any of the acts that that this group
has
perpetrated uh in the name of religion
and
uh it has it's a king with no clothes it
can say whatever it wants
i could i could pretend to be a
christian a buddhist a hindu
a jewish an an atheist and do you know
anything i wanted and just pretend that
i'm doing it in the name of something
doesn't mean that gives any credibility
to
uh you know your actions speak louder
than your words uh people sometimes get
spooked out when you say uh
they've heard you say fundamentalist but
if you're a doctor you you follow the
fundamentals of medicine
of course engineering fundamentals of
engineering uh christianity fundamentals
that you follow in the fundamentals of
islam
the abcs i mean you know i'm a
fundamentalist muslim in that
i believe that there's no compulsion in
religion i believe that
god has sent guidance to mankind and
says that you know there's god there's
heaven there's hell there's a day of
judgment
live your life accordingly treat others
the way you want to be treated
act as if you're in the presence of god
at all time
and be fair be just be noble be
steadfast do
everything that you can to be a better
person a better human being
and be helpful to others and this is
the essence of all religious traditions
and especially islam
now what do you think i mean we condemn
this obviously this has nothing to do
with islam
obviously but now when when other people
they look and they say what about
the rest of humanity coming out if we
condemn one shouldn't we condemn all we
have innocent people dying children i
mean hundreds of thousands have died in
syria
in palestine and what is your take on
this
well i think that we should be screaming
from rooftops about every
unjust and
[Music]
ethical act performed by anybody so what
is happening to the palestinians what's
happening in syria
what's happening in bangladesh what's
happening in egypt what's happening
in uh almost every or
many countries all over the world today
there's it's just full of injustice
full of oppression full of just
you name it atrocities
and every one of those human beings that
are being affected should have our
concerns should have our heart
should have our prayers should be
somebody that we
try to help
so my heart is for every one of the
syrians and every one of the
palestinians and
all of the jewish people or anybody
that's being hurt
innocently for doing nothing and being a
victim of
others aggression and um
injustice uh tell us uh what do you uh
when you see um and it's kind of
disheartening what's your take on this
when you when just
today you um have uh this week in the
news you had a gunman he went in and
killed a few people
wounded 11 almost a dozen and
you know it's interesting gunmen suspect
every other name but what it is
he committed terrorist terrorism right
what is your take on this
well it's it's an obvious uh double
standard
but uh again i would uh condemn that
individual
as much as i would isis or anybody else
um
i think uh today uh the media has
decided that uh
only muslims can be terrorists so if
anybody does anything
equivalent to something that is being
called terrorism
they'll find another word for a
non-muslim so it's kind of an exclusive
club
at the moment to be
a terrorist activity but you could
definitely call
what assad is doing to his own people
terrorism you could say
what is happening in bangladesh and you
know new parties taken over and
ruthlessly killing parties that uh
you know want to silence their
opposition you can call
every uh genocide every murder every
um act of terror terrorism
and you should if you're going to be
consistent but i think it's more of a
political term than an
accurate definition at the moment when
we come back when you get your take on
some more current events here on the
dean show don't go anywhere we'll be
right back
so what is it that we still don't
understand when we claim to follow
islam yet we fail to follow
this man i mean i know a man who was
so caring and compassionate who said
that there is a reward in serving
all things that are animate in other
words everything that breeds
whether it be the animals the trees and
every single human being
i mean if allah called him
[Music]
how dare you call him anything else that
contravenes see this is a man who said
that the muslim was he who is soft
simple and lenient a man who taught us
himself to be cautious from
falling into extremism see he was never
given two choices except he chose that
which was easiest
not for himself but for his people and
that convenience
see i know a man who advocated for the
freedom of the slaves
a man who taught us that the muslim is
the one from whom the people are safe
not only from his hands but even from
the words that he says
see this is a man who would never mark
mimic nor ridicule
nor would he ever publicly rebuke an
individual
this is the man i follow so forgive me
if this sounds unusual
but the man i know was so much more
handsome
so beautiful please subscribe to the d
show follow us on our official facebook
and twitter pages in the links below
please also help support the d show by
making a donation in the link below
back here on the d show now you actually
you accepted you came
when we did our first uh sit down we had
a meeting we talked about
um your your journey to islam you
actually came from a baptist christian
yeah i was an aspiring baptist minister
that uh converted in 1989 so 25 years
ago i became muslim
and how's it been ever since i love
islam i love the muslim community
i want to do anything or everything i
can to
to help the muslims the humanity at
large so
i am very happy to have 25 years
of being a muslim and that's simply one
i mean always you know from
uh doing the program that you you just
chosen to submit your will to the
creator of heavens and earth just like
jesus did moses abraham they all
submitted to god that's it
um and and when you hear people like
donald trump
you know kind of they they equate it to
like what hitler was going to do with
the with the jews uh
registration for muslims what is your
take on this
well i think it's insane um uh
you know a national id card for muslims
is exactly
repeating history and you know the cries
of never again
seem to be uh short in everyone's memory
um if you'll look back on
the most egregious
for the lack of better term genocides it
all started with
stigmatizing a group of people
dehumanizing them
treating them with you know id cards and
and
everybody separating them from
the the norm and then uh people's
uh angers frustration and aggression
eventually are being would be taken out
against that
minority and it can lead to nothing good
so
it's it's a it's a solution that has
proven itself to be
horrible and should never be repeated
most of these when you had also not too
long ago the
individual who went in who committed uh
act of terror also against innocent
muslims he went in and killed
that was in texas also the three doctors
was it a
young lady and her two brothers went and
shot him point blank
are you talking about the muslims that
got shot yes it was in north carolina
north carolina chapel hill north chapel
hill that's what it was yeah
when he was asked uh have you ever met a
muslim or anything
no he had no idea so can we be i mean
this when people experience that human
connection with muslims you know some
people in these rural areas never met a
muslim but
how important is for us now to really
get out there you know to help educate
to edify the people well here's
something that
i think every muslim should do and that
is
let people know you're muslim and then
practice islam
to the best of your ability and let
people see
your your manners your etiquette and
your
your religion coming through you and
your actions and not your words
and there have been studies on this
though this is something that
there's empirical data there are not
research that has been done where
hundreds if not thousands of people have
been interviewed about their
uh thoughts on islam and muslims
and this was after 9 11 people were
asked okay so what do you think about
islam what do you think about muslims
and they ask them many different
questions and at the end of the survey
they asked
each participant the same question and
that is
rate yourself on your own knowledge
of islam and muslims so you could pick i
know nothing
i know a little bit i know somewhat or i
know a lot
and you rate yourself and you get the
results of those surveys back
and the overwhelming majority of all the
answers are negative
so the survey tells you that there is a
non-favorable impression of islam and
muslims
but if you take all of the surveys and
you sort them by
okay who in this pile said that they
they rate themselves as knowing nothing
how many of you said you know somewhat
how many you know i mean a little
somewhat or a lot and you have four
piles
and you look at the ones who say they
know nothing you see the most hostile
venomous hatred towards islam and
muslims
but if you go to the ones who say i know
a little bit about islam and muslims
their answers were more favorable if
they know somewhat
about islam and muslims this is their
own definition of themselves
more favorable and the ones who claim to
know a lot about islam and muslims
had the most favorable impression of
islam and muslims
so what that survey tells us is the more
information people have
about real islam and muslims the more
favorable their impression becomes
so that means all of us as muslims are
put in a circle of influence
in our life our daily lives whatever we
do and however we do it
we come in contact with people and the
people are looking
at us as representatives of that faith
and we need to be the best examples
of what we believe in our circle of
influence and we can change the world
we can change that impression before we
we cut out uh
for this program uh this week's program
tell us a little bit about the work that
you do
um you know for people who want to get
involved help and
uh maybe call you out well yeah
i'm one of the co-founders and the
current executive director
of a charity called the muslim legal
fund of america
the muslim legal fund was founded in
and it is what its name proclaims it's a
charity that collects money so all i do
is go all over the u.s and i collect
money from the muslim community
and with the money that we collect we
spend the money on lawyers
we hire attorneys to defend muslim
rights in court
so we have taken cases like the holy
land foundation dr afiyah siddiqui dr
samuel arion the irvine 11 the 60 moms
hundreds of cases involving our imams
leaders activists organizations or
anyone
who we feel is being dealt with unfairly
by the legal system
and as a charity
we continue to grow and today we've
opened a non-profit law firm where we've
now
after 14 years of working with some of
the best attorneys in the nation
we've actually ask a few of them to
close their law firms
and to work full-time at a non-profit
law firm called the constitutional law
center for muslims
in america this law firm is going to be
solely funded by the muslim legal fund
it's grant funding to the law firm
these lawyers will work full time for
the muslim community
on immigration civil or criminal issues
nationwide
and for free so if you like what you
hear you can donate if you need our
service give us a call
and this is a charity that really
believes that
that everyone is entitled to
fair and equal treatment under the law
and if we don't see it happening
we think that the community should
support each other in that process
what's the website that people can
contact
you can visit the website at
[Music]
www.mlfa.org
muslim legal fund of america mlfa dot
org it's always a pleasure thank you so
much
for being with us look forward to that
appreciate it thank you peace be with
you god bless you so much
and that was our special guest here with
us on the deenshot i hope you got the
benefit i surely did
don't believe the hype learn about islam
from the muslims call us 1-800-662-islam
get to know islam you see what happened
when people knew a little bit
knew somewhat of islam the hate started
to go away but imagine those who
really immersed themselves into learning
islam sincerely
right with the intention the right
intention removing all those prejudices
and
hate that hatred that you've been taught
because
nobody's born hating you've been taught
this stuff remove it
learn about islam from the muslims sit
with the muslim because muslim is one
who just
submits himself or herself entirely to
the one who created
us the one created the same created
jesus worship and call people to worship
those are the muslims get to know your
fellow muslim
and you'll see many of these
apprehensions you might have will
quickly
go away call us again subscribe if you
haven't already and tune in here to the
show every week for a new exciting show
we'll see you next time until then
peace be with you a man who taught
kindness to the neighbors
who taught us to serve others without
expecting back any favors
to spread peace to those we know and
even to the strangers
to walk with humility and to simply
ignore the haters
but nevertheless i know a man who still
taught us to
stand up for the oppressed from the men
women and children who
call out to us in distress and we're a
man who taught us to
fight for these people but by no means
does this mean we have the
right to transgress for those who
oppress have
nothing to do with his name so you can
say what you wish to say
and continue to defame his name but at
the end of the day i assure you
the man i follow was not the same
muhammad
[Music]
please subscribe to the show follow us
on our official facebook and twitter
pages in the links below
please also help support the d show by
making a donation in the link below